MARKUS KLUTE: Hello.
Welcome back to 8.701.
In this short video, we will
talk about charge conjugation.
Charge conjugation
is the transformation
which switches all particles
to their corresponding
antiparticles and vice versa.
So you have a
particle p, you apply
charge conjugation
on this particle,
and you receive
its antiparticle.
This changes all signs of
internal quantum numbers--
the charge, the baryon number,
the lepton number, strangeness,
charmness, and so on.
But at leaves the mass,
the energy, the momentum,
and the spin untouched.
The electromagnetic and
strong interactions,
they obey charged symmetry.
But the weak interaction
violates charge symmetry.
So charge conjugation, it's a
multiplicative quantum number,
like parity.
You get identity if you apply
charge conjugation twice.
You make an
antiparticle, and then
you apply this to
the antiparticle,
you get the particle back.
Only particles that are
their own antiparticles
can be eigenstates
of this symmetry.
You can see this here.
When you apply this, you either
get a positive or negative
sign.
But this is only valid
for particles who
are their own antiparticles.
As elementary particles,
that only leaves the photon.
As composite particles,
you will see later
that there is a
number of mesons which
can be their own antiparticles.
But we'll discuss this
in subsequent lectures.
By itself, there's limited
use to the symmetry
in order to learn things.
There are some examples,
and we'll discuss them
in a recitation, where you can
learn about possible decays,
for example, in
pions, neutral pions,
from applying this symmetry,
without knowing really
what is the underlying physics.
But in the next
lecture, we then talk
about CP, the multiplication of
parity and charge conjugation,
and some of the interesting
effects which occur from this.